[Music]
and cambrie's news yeah I think that
little ball just kind of like to go
there why is it so funny to watch people
choke I know submitted by Alejo May yeah
you're pronouncing recognize a 325 pound
woman has been charged with homicide
after sitting on her nine year old
cousin that said yeah did she know that
she said no you have to know nine year
old 325 pounds at how tall is she I
don't know good night you see yeah she's
like five foot seven yeah I know what
you guys are gonna do you guys are gonna
fat shame this lady and say oh my god
she's so fat she crushed the boy living
it let's laugh at the fat girl but no
you know what why were you I think this
is you know we need we need to change
the world because it's it is because we
think people like you who think like
this that's why me yes you
like you I heard it I heard it you even
need to say it that you think she's fat
[Laughter]
I know it does sound like these jokes
are made from nobody so straight up
though there are those cases worth like
women that size who have children they
don't even know that they gave birth
until they go to the bathroom maybe
think it's like constipation because
they're so large so I wouldn't be
surprised if they crush the truck no but
didn't like they usually crush babies
and the babies can't move 25 and you're
like 5 foot 5 or something like that
you're pretty round how did the kid get
under the lady I guarantee you how to
turn out do yoga and then he thought she
was doing a bridge and then she fell and
while under the bridge came down oh did
way like that question is did he did she
did she suffocated him or dishes like
snap his neck right like that yeah yeah
so different are you yeah I will answer
all these questions ok so and I'll get
to that one ok I love you
alright so Veronica okay
so Veronica 64 years old she's arrested
and charged with homicide and cruelty
toward Ohio this was on purpose it was
oh you [ __ ] [ __ ] you I hope you [ __ ]
die she's playing pancake so it happened
here was that you trying to hatch shake
just cuz she fat doesn't be she's a
criminal
come on all those is so great 69 years
old and James they are the parents of
darica nine-year-old 69 no popped out a
baby at 60 years no it was an adopted
child I'm not sure how they they got
this child but she also had a sister and
the sisters not not harmed and I don't
know what her age is either and I don't
know how these people go answer the
questions before we add to them learned
your guyses ways yeah so anyway so grace
called
Veronica over to their home to hunt like
to discipline America because apparently
she wasn't listening and so that's when
Veronica decided to sit on darica as a
punishment ah and so she sat on her and
and then derecho was telling her like I
can't breathe I can't breathe but she
still sat on her oh she's out on the
girl for 10 minute yeah and what 25
pounds [ __ ] you
that's [ __ ] heavy you know what's
crazy is that this person used sitting
as a form of punishment like sitting on
someone like she really knew what kind
of damage she could do with her fat ass
it's pretty I heard it's pretty common
like you some parents just sit on their
kids like yeah what the [ __ ] you think
you're doing mode let me just sit on
there's like the laziest thing yeah you
could do a lot of damage we don't do
jack [ __ ] or you're just like they can't
move yeah you've been thrown into a
closet before no see that's the weird we
think to the asian people do they wrap
you in a blanket that throw you in the
closet not in the blanket okay no they
just put you in the closet in the dark
they're saying that the Department of
Children and Families children's
quashing is they issued a statement
calling the child's death appalling yet
said that the agency will work with the
Sheriff's Office to hold those response
for her death accountable and so now
Veronica she was released on a 127
thousand dollar bail and then the the
parent they still are in jail the grace
hers bond is set at $75,000 and james
bond is at fifty thousand dollars and so
they're both of the parents they were
charged with neglect mmm cruelty towards
a child that's what the parent all
charged with for a fat [ __ ] she lived
pretty well she's living for a long time
so to show you how amazing the human
body is worth waiting that's the whole
it's two guys that was the same person
this is Grace and this is that's great
but she has a beard I think of a four
and after yeah matching shirts not as a
joke that's that's for a woman yeah
woman oh [ __ ] okay it's starting to look
like a woman if you just focus on this
side right here don't okay get away from
the beard and the balding head lady no
that's a dude no that's a lady
absolutely so there was a the neighbors
nearby they were being interviewed and
they were saying like we are so shocked
these these parents they're such good
parents they always treat the kids
really well they even go walking around
the block with the two girls and like
they were saying like yeah remember when
when she was a baby girl and they got
her they didn't explain how they got
these kids though so I'm not sure about
that so the neighbors are saying that
these are really great parents they had
never seen Veronica ever in the
neighborhood or even anywhere near them
so they're just like shocked they're
like this whole neighborhood is just
really shocked that this happened that
this little girl died this family looks
like a potato family people always gonna
say stuff like that like oh I never knew
my neighbor was a molester and had three
people under the basement like people
you never suspect your neighbor to go oh
every time on those uh you know those
news interviews did you know you were
living next door to a meth lab I have no
idea they always came outside we you
know we even
I've invited them to our barbecue yeah
it like no one's gonna know that's
people everyone has like eight faces and
that's just one of their eight besides
being a potato head you know like mr.
Potato Head that feel what made you pick
the number eight
well because two faces is too basic okay
cuz everyone has more than two faces
you got your work face you got your
family phase you got your relationship
based you got your friends shape face
you got the way you treat your kids face
you got your school face if you go to
school or your professional face and
then you got Joe i'ma fight you because
I don't like you face you know I mean
you got the one that you share by
yourself when you jack off you have your
vlog face that's nine oh so we have nine
pieces yeah so I'm wondering of
Instagram face tooth so this one yeah
Veronica killed the kid and the parents
do you think the parents are equally
guilty or like they didn't know what was
going on or they knew what was going on
I didn't stop it that's a good question
right right I mean they are being
charged so really like the cover must
have some sort of keep did you just sit
on the kid like on the couch or on the
floor a chair a chair
they say it was a chair wasn't bicep
non-church what if she was like honestly
guys anything else bad fat oh that's her
testimony though is like first of all
this is where a fat person and where is
she
yeah she's like cuz I mean it's like if
you sat on Isaac you're not gonna kill
him you know that but we'll add a mouth
German Tappan yeah obviously like it's
assault with a deadly weapon if you're
like 500 pounds right mm-hmm
yeah that's true cuz I bombed my friend
and when I was a kid we just jump up and
use
oh my god is this friend alive well we
were both fat it was so
we were doing it to each other but he
[ __ ] up because he had his hands like
this and then he dislocated his wrist oh
[ __ ] and then there were like well this
was done by a very large child and I
said well who that who is that child I
did it
she didn't blame this packet for it was
it that the most interest thing you've
ever heard in your whole entire life
I don't even know what you guys just
talked about but anyways please
subscribe for more random videos more
funny content and more hahaha poopoo in
your pants stuff go ahead subscribe and
for more videos right now